el-shafi al-shaikh will spend the rest
of his life in prison the 33-year-old
jihadist a former british citizen seen
here with his co-defendant alexander
cote was convicted of lethal
hostage-taking and conspiracy to murder
it was the killing of the american
journalist james foley that brought isis
to the world's attention the sentence
came on the eighth anniversary of his
death it was just not planned
but
appropriate i'm grateful um our god must
have planned this
his mother dianne told me her son's
memory would never die addressing el
shake in court she said your hatred
overtook your humanity he has no desire
to talk to us
and interact with us at all
so i tend to think he feels very
i don't know
strong in his conviction that what he
did was somehow right i don't know how
he can think that and i pray that time
will give will change his heart
the third isis beetle muhammad and wazey
known as jihadi john was killed in a
drone strike the terror cells victims
included british aid workers david
haynes and alan henning the body of
usaid worker kayla mueller has never
been recovered for her parents and the
other families the pain of loss will
never end but they hope the u.s
government will respond quicker in
future they definitely have have learned
their lesson and our children
was the cost
of that
and hopefully in the future our
government will do like so many others
did and get their people home
not leave them there for 18 months
during victim impact statements monica
pieto the wife of a spanish hostage who
survived recalled how her son slept on
his bedroom floor to be in the same
position as his dad and how their
daughter rang his mobile just to leave
voice messages
daniel otterson a danish hostage
explained that the horror of what they
experienced was easier to bear than the
silence
referring to will shake he said he will
now sit in silence and think and that is
very scary
the judge described ill-shake as
horrific barbaric brutal callous and of
course criminal
he will never be eligible for parole
david blevins sky news in virginia